we've been in this topic of quadratics
for some time now right and you guys
know what a quadratic is it's something
that looks like this looks like this
it's called a quadratic a quadratic
because a quadratic four-sided thing
you're squaring right your screen that's
what makes it a quadratic if you've got
you know for example just that 6x plus 5
that's a lot of quadratic it'd just be a
straight line if I had some different
number up there like 3 or 4 or 5 it's
still something we can work with but
it's not a quadratic okay these are
we've been focusing on and these this is
such a big idea in you 10 but also
particularly in 5.3 leading to to unit
because just like tree excuse me
quadratics have all of these
applications they lead to all these
important matter years and it's kind of
like a foundational skill right now one
of the big ideas that quadratics goes to
is graphing and it goes there for our
intents and purposes it goes there in
two ways and that's what is over here on
the right hand side okay so firstly
we're going to look at just what happens
when you try to graphically represent
draw sketch a quadratic like this and
you'll get a parabola you've seen this
shape before okay but secondly good
morning we're going to talk about points
of intersection between various kinds of
graphs that aren't actually quadratics
but you need your skill in quadratics so
you find those points of intersection it
will make sense when I show you some
examples okay so we're gonna start just
by trying to draw these parabolas right
and you have drawn simple travelers
before but we're gonna step it up a
little bit and what I've given you here
is kind of like a skeleton or a
structure or a guide for how to draw a
parabola here's the picture I have in my
head right my problem looks like this
yeah
he might be a problem okay and it has an
equation that goes with it in order to
work out what this thing looks like okay
there are a couple of different
alternatives that you could take for
instance the method that we would use
when we know nothing about any kind of
graph is you draw something like this
draw a table and then you say okay I'm
just going to take some values of X like
0 1 & 2 I'm gonna stick them in and find
out what is equal to 4 why this is
called our what's a called it's a table
what's in the table a bunch of values so
it's called up table of values created
isn't it anyway
this table of values it works just fine
right except for the fact that it's
super slow and it also doesn't show
really any understanding of like
literally it's what you do what you
don't understand
I don't know but I could put your values
I can substitute your stuff in not the
best approach and that's why I'm going
to show you this new one okay now
without doing this how do you work out
where it goes okay and the metaphor I
want you to have in your mind is the
metaphor of a forensic scientist right
so friends this is like oh I'm trying to
solve a crime and you walk in the client
already over and all that's left is like
clues little bits of evidence okay and
from those little piece of evidence
you've got to work out what actually
what was the story that bound all
together okay so this this set of things
here are the pieces of evidence the
clues that we're going to use a
correspond to at this point these two
points and possibly not one I think
Jordan a very good spot okay now once
you know those two or three or four
spots you know everything you need to
know about that parabola just literally
need to join up the dots you've got all
the clues you need and you know exactly
what shape it's gonna be looking like so
what do we need to work out okay I'm
gonna guide you through the steps and
then we'll give it that go with an
example okay given any quadratic and any
quadratic you can write this one down
though you've seen it before any
quadratic will be in this form right ax
squared plus BX plus C you might
remember
this fall has a special name it's called
general form
it's called general form because any
quadratic can be written in this form
right
not every quadratic can be factorized
but every quadratic can just be written
on there like that okay so the first
thing we want to know it out of this is
for graphing sake something called the
y-intercept right now you guys have seen
and heard of y-intercepts before you've
heard of it with straight lines what
does it mean to say y-intercept
it's that phrase me fantastic that's
perfect intercept means when two things
like collide when they hit each other
right so you've got the y-axis here and
where you hit the y-axis or rather the
way the parabola does right we call that
the y-intercept
okay now there's a super easy way to
work out where the y-intercept is how do
you find a y-intercept like if I give
you a straight line my is how would you
work out what its y-intercept was
because we've done the straight lines
for a while now
any takers okay fantastic you you do two
things right first you would say see
this y-intercept right there are X
values that go along all the X values on
the wound axis are zero okay cuz you
haven't gone to the left you haven't
gone to the right your bang in the
middle x equals zero okay so if I put x
equals zero into here x equals zero then
I will pop a value or Y value in this
case two times zero zero minus five so
in fact it's just that guy over there
okay if I hope that rings some bells in
straight lines you have lines in this
form y equals MX plus B what's M into
the gradient and what's B B is the
y-intercept okay
in fact morning in fact I didn't even
really need to do this if I hadn't
ordered the nice form that I've got it I
actually say there's the number minus
five because as soon as you say x equals
zero or your X is just disappear okay
now you come and have a look at this for
a second
ax squared plus BX plus C if I do the
same thing putting X equal zero what
happens to these guys up the front here
they all just vanish away because when x
equals zero I didn't care what a is I
don't care what B is they've got to get
both x 0 ok so when x equals 0 what gets
left behind
it's just this guy in the end isn't it
see just like B got left behind over
here C gets left here so therefore to
find a way to staff good morning all I
need is the value of C it's just that
number on the end you just read it you
don't have to do any work just look at
ok that was step one step two is very
similar right we need to find the
x-intercepts and you'll notice I say
plural right so we did the y-intercepts
that's where I'm keeping up here but I
say its intercepts plural because as you
can see just from my pretend diagram of
the key I can have more than one kana if
I frequently I will have two okay I
might not have to I might just have one
if my clown hole looks like this reasons
see how I just collide once I could just
have one or alternatively some of the
premise we looked at they just have no
roots see that parabola there that I
just drew right it's very small but it's
facing downwards and it never comes back
up it never sort of turns around again
so it's always down below and never
comes back to the answers okay
so we're going to find the x intercept
now remember you told me that to find
the Y necessity would I let X equal 0
so if I let X equal 0 to get this how do
I find the x-intercepts I should do it
the other way should I should let y
equal 0
should there Y is here ok now you can
see just came back to my general form
right if I let y equal 0 then the
equation looks like this now these you
should be sick to death huh right
because we looked at how to solve these
you could factorize you
complete the square you could use the
quadratic formula if you can't do
anything else right so these you know
how to solve right let y equal zero and
they treat it just like one of the
problems you've done before
okay you can see how this process of
graphing brings together a lot of the
skills that you can use for straight
lines and factorizing and so on okay
just one other point of interest the
answer the sets because they're so
important they also get another name
they've also called roots okay
okay now I don't know if you're gonna
feel that yeah well so I said find the
x-intercepts right so if you're solving
something like this we frequently not
always and I about to talk about that
the second we frequently get two values
will get two okay so I'm going to place
them both onto my graph and I'll show
you with this example okay all right
that was a good question now as I just
said you know it's x-intercepts plural
um it might be I mean strictly speaking
I should have like a bracket around that
s because I might just have one
x-intercept or I might have none that
that happens okay it's not that hard to
come up with a quadratic that doesn't
have roots okay so therefore you know
like when you're filling out a form it
says I do so and so if not skin to
question fire okay that's what we're
gonna do here there's only one more step
we're gonna do if you can't find any
roots if things just break down you do
the quadratic formula and there's like a
negative number under the square root
that's okay we're going to this next
step okay if you're gonna widen set you
got X into sense the last thing you want
is actually a pair of features the first
one is the axis okay now I I'm ention
this very very quickly on Tuesday okay
I remember for me this is what the
quadratic formula looks like do you
remember that this is the quadratic
formula we we came up with it by
completing the square right now what we
did very very briefly on Tuesday just as
a teaser for you today as I said wait a
second look at this thing I know we've
written it as one fraction but we can
write it as two we can break
like this okay now why would you bother
doing this and the answer is to help you
see parabola czar all symmetrical right
every parabola you draw you can reflect
it across and you get the same shape
okay which means that when you look at
the roots these roots okay if you think
about the axis of symmetry
I need another color this axis of
symmetry going right down the middle
okay to work out whether it's art you
may need to same color you go from the
axis to the right that gives you one of
the ribs and then you go to the left
that gives you the other one I hope that
diagram looks a little bit familiar okay
that corresponds to the right and left
corresponds through the plus and the
minus so here at this part minus B on to
a that's the bit of the middle plus or
minus that takes you to the roots on the
outside okay so where is this axis of
symmetry my people who donít loan it's
at here we go
x equals minus B on to a okay now this
is really wonderful important and it's
why if you can't find roots you just go
straight to this step every parabola has
a y-intercept every parabola has an axis
of surgery because they're all
symmetrical okay
so even if you can't find roots that's
alright let's still find an axis right
now this is something that didn't
mention on Tuesday we're not just gonna
add by finding the axis I'm gonna use
the axis to find something else
important another one of my clues called
the vertex okay now the vertex is this
top spot right or alternatively if my
power problems going the other way that
it would be the bottom spot that's a
pretty important spot of the parabola
right so all I've got is these
intercepts and this vertex being on the
top or the bottom how I find that I will
show you in this example it'll be a bit
easier to illustrate okay
so let's give this a crack usually in
the past where you know oh I've got to
graph something you will start right
away by drawing a set of axes okay I'm
going to deliberately ask you
not to do that okay here's one see these
brothers that I've thrown up here I drew
three of them right do you notice how
this one's like kind of awkward it's
like stuck down here in the bottom okay
because I didn't draw my axes with
enough space right I drew all this space
up here which I don't need and I didn't
turn up space down here where I did need
it okay now how do you know where you
need to have space how do you know am I
supposed to go up we're supposed to go
down to the left to the right and saw
you look at the clues okay so we're
going to work out the clues first and
then we'll draw a set of axes in exactly
the right spot that we do okay